[Musica]
questa bambina che cammina per le strade
di mogadiscio durante le vacanze con suo
padre sono io e la foto è stata scattata
da mia madre mia madre è nata in
calabria e della prima di sette figli
mio padre primogenito di 17 figli 10
maschi e 7 femmine è nato in somalia la
somalia è uno dei paesi insieme ad altri
30 paesi del mondo in cui la mutilazione
genitale femminile è un rito
profondamente radicato un rito che da
stato sociale e accettazione totali alla
bambina che diventa donna ea tutta la
sua famiglia
questa pratica esiste tra religioni e
culture diverse nel mondo si stima che
sono 200 milioni le donne e le bambine a
rischio o che hanno già subito una
mutilazione dei genitali in europa si
parla di 500mila donne in italia di
circa 35 mila e in svizzera dove lavoro
di circa 22.000 nonostante le dimensioni
di questo fenomeno sono ancora pochi
medici con le conoscenze e le competenze
culturali mediche e chirurgiche per
prevenire e curare le conseguenze delle
mutilazioni genitali
i miei genitori entrambi i ginecologi
sono stati tra i primi ad occuparsi di
questo fenomeno in italia ea firenze
hanno aperto un centro di riferimento
per la prevenzione e la cura delle
mutilazioni genitali femminili
io sono cresciuta a contatto col loro
lavoro
una volta diventata grande e sono
diventata anche un medico ostetrico
ginecologo il ginecologo formata e
medicina sessuale specialista della cura
delle complicanze delle mutilazioni
genitali femminili e nel 2010 agli
ospedali universitari di ginevra ho
aperto un ambulatorio per accogliere
informare e trattare le bambine le donne
con mutilazione genitale femminile le
pazienti vengono nel nostro ambulatorio
per diversi motivi principalmente
complicanze legate a questa pratica
quindi problemi urinari dolori
cronici problemi ostetrici psicologici
se suo logici oppure vengono per un
trattamento chirurgico ricostruttivo
alcune donne che non soffrono di
complicanze vengono per essere informate
su un argomento che rimane tabù non solo
tra le comunità dove questa pratica e
tradizionale ma anche tra i medici ci
sono diversi tipi di mutilazione
genitale dalla cultura o incisione del
prepuzio del clitoride al taglio del
clitoride al taglio delle labbra
conoscenza taglio della parte esterna è
visibile del clitoride fino
all'infibulazione che è il
restringimento dell'orifizio vaginale
con il taglio o meno delle labbra del
clitoride è la struttura delle labbra e
poi esistono molte altre pratiche sugli
organi genitali dannose a scopo non
terapeutico vi parlerò del lavoro di
cura all'ambulatorio cura che inizia con
l'accoglienza l'informazione l'ascolto
il trattamento che lou reed con me
chirurgico o medico per promuovere la
salute fisica psicologica sessuale e
sociale salute fisica le mutilazioni
genitali possono causare gravi
conseguenze sulla salute delle bambine e
delle donne
una donna infibulata per esempio può
tardare diversi minuti per svuotare la
vescica o soffrire di infezioni o dolori
invalidanti oppure di un parto difficile
e molto spesso la donna può non essere
consapevole che quel sintomo è legato
alla sua mutilazione per esempio il
trattamento dell'infibulazione la defi
bull azione che consiste nell'aprire gli
organi fibula ti ricostruendo le labbra
ma dove l'infibulazione tradizionale
esistono tanti miti tante false credenze
sugli organi fibula ti chiusi che sono
immaginati come puliti puri belli sexy e
soprattutto garanzia per un buon
matrimonio urinare goccia a goccia senza
fare rumore
considerato educato femminile i genitali
aperti invece sono immaginati come degli
organi brutti sporchi dove l'aria può
entrare e portare delle infezioni per
esempio quindi anche quando una donna
soffre di complicanze estremamente gravi
può a volte rifiutare il trattamento per
paura per diffidenza o a causa di queste
credenze e quindi è necessario conoscere
la cultura dell'altro ascoltare
informare e piano piano rendere la donna
informata perché possa decidere
liberamente per la sua salute
riconoscere curare le conseguenze delle
mutilazioni genitali vuol dire dare una
vita senza dolore urinare e mestruale
normalmente partorire e fisiologicamente
vuol dire rinascita una rinascita fisica
porta una rinascita psicologico molte
bambine e donne con mutilazioni genitali
femminili sono donne immigrate o
rifugiati che hanno vissuto altre
violenza in passato traumi un percorso
drammatico migratorio la perdita di
persone care una guerra e molto spesso
non hanno mai parlato di questi eventi
passati nei della loro mutilazione
genitale né di salute sessuale e
riproduttiva e quindi appunto dicevo che
molto spesso non hanno mai parlato di
questi argomenti che sono tabù non solo
nelle comunità ma anche tra i medici
stessi quindi venire in ambulatorio
parlare per la prima volta di questi
argomenti avere interprete certificato
perché molte donne parlano un'altra
lingua e avere un supporto psicologico
permette piano piano di sviluppare delle
strategie per elaborare questi eventi
passati e che hanno piano superarli con
la promozione della salute fisica e
psicologica si può promuovere poi la
salute sessuale
in molte comunità che praticano le
mutilazioni genitali femminili si pensa
che il clitoride sia un organo che può
crescere e rendere una donna
ipersessuale incontrollabile con
comportamenti totalmente disonorevoli
tagliare il clitoride quindi renderebbe
una donna sessualmente più calma molte
donne e molte comunità dove queste
pratiche si effettuano pensano però che
il clitoride sia un organo piccolo e
questa credenza esiste anche tra i
medici che molto spesso non conoscono
l'anatomia sessuale femminile
in realtà il clitoride commissive né in
queste ricostruzioni tridimensionali
alla risonanza magnetica è un organo che
misura 12 centimetri e la parte che è
interessata dal taglio e la punta il
grande più o meno il corpo del clitoride
e tutte le altre strutture che
circondano la vagina sono ancora intatte
quindi possono rispondere agli stimoli
la ricostruzione del clitoride per
esempio consiste nel riesporre questo
organo che è sotto la cicatrice
in più la salute sessuale femminile non
dipende solo dalla punta dell'organo
quindi curare le cause dei dolori
offrire un supporto psico sessuale ea
volte scoprire per la prima volta che il
clitoride ancora presente e funzionante
permette di promuovere la salute
sessuale permette alle donne di scoprire
per la prima volta qualcosa che si
pensava perduto per sempre permette di
scoprire il piacere e il benessere
sessuale attraverso la salute fisica
psicologica e sessuale si può ottenere
anche una migliore salute e sociale che
naturalmente dipende da tanti fattori
tuttavia molte bambine o donne che
arrivano in un paese ospite possono
iniziare a farsi delle domande a
sentirsi diverse e non socialmente
accettati con l'informazione
la terapia il trattamento la mutilazione
fisica smette di essere una mutilazione
della salute e questo vuol dire
rinascita
la donna può riaffacciarsi alla sua vita
al lavoro alla sua famiglia alla società
senza le conseguenze dannose e spesso
dolorose di queste pratiche scoprire di
essere una donna normale completo che
può provare piacere avere benessere
essere in salute
tutto questo come diceva una rinascita
ma anche una nascita la nascita di una
generazione di bambini che non saranno
mutilate e non per questo socialmente
escluse
grazie
[Applauso]